okay you had to recently dispel rumors
that you had undergone plastic surgery
you actually experienced your jaw being
shattered what in 2013. what did you
make of the speculation online your mom
was even the one that brought it up to
you like what's going on
why did you feel like you had to address
those rumors now
I didn't really
really no I when my mom told me I don't
really read the internet
um
yeah it was it was just if if that's the
direction that it was going it's maybe
it's time to get plastic surgery you
wouldn't get that come on you got a good
job man
oh my God
you're just stirring the pot no it was
funny it sucked I almost died but we're
good but you're good now yeah good
that's good to see in a healthy happy
place what are we doing
we're going to run for our lives
we're halfway home halfway I'm chicky
Donahue and I am not supposed to be in
Vietnam what a journey this is wild
quite the beer run on site now Zach this
was a film that you fought long and hard
for to take on this role what about
chickie were you like I have got to take
on this part what was so compelling to
you you know all of it it's just hard to
believe that this was a true story it
seemed
so crazy dangerous and yet
i i as the character progresses and goes
through the Vietnam War he's he's really
changed yeah and it's also woven really
beautifully with this kind of underlying
humor that is just Pete's style that
he's really really good at and I knew he
was going to make this something special
so I it had everything in my mind that I
want to do checking all the boxes right
well how did this guy check your box of
chicky over here fantastic yes he was
I keep telling people this he reminded
me of Travolta and Saturday Night Fever
what yes Zach did you hear that we got
it on today
it's a flawed character who makes a lot
of mistakes but he he's always trying to
improve himself and his heart's in the
right place and he's really really good
looking and uh they remind you of each
other I'm a huge Travolta fan and he was
he he felt like provoking this yeah
that's really how chicky is those are
accolades right there Zach take me down
the Journey of transforming into chickie
the stash the accent were you saying in
accent out of takes whenever he was
yelling cut how did that play out for
you sort of you there's I it's what's
incredible is I thought I was never
gonna lose that accent at the end of the
movie I was like oh this is never I'm
gonna be talking like this for a long
time I was like thinking about these
interviews being like I want to be able
to do an accident on it and it's it's
actually pretty hard yeah but I had a
great uh dialect coach Jerome Butler
he's fantastic
yeah yeah and within it within like a
week that we were something close to a
pretty specific accent the way Chickie's
voice is like iconic I don't know how to
describe it it's just the real tricky
yeah like it's a larger than life accent
and he's just it's so charming and
endearing yeah so I'd like to go over to
Vietnam track down all the boys in the
neighborhood and give them a beer I
do what bringing beer he's not serious
he's hammered look at him the man stoned
soba that's his fifth beer maybe tops
I'm going to Vietnam and I'm bringing a
beer so this is the first film that
you've brought to fan since greenba same
writing team yeah well no no well Brian
Curry was on both and Pete Jones wrote
this with us he came on he I worked with
him on hall pass a few years ago okay
okay yes well are we thinking maybe
Lightning's gonna strike twice look you
had a dynamic team then for green book
you've got Zach in this film yeah you've
got wrestle Crowe you've got Bill Murray
yeah I mean that sounds like a trip to
award season right there I don't ever
think about that honestly and and and I
certainly didn't in this one because you
know it's a it's a war movie you don't
you don't expect you just want to
entertain people true but it's based on
a true story that's always compelling
and it's a phenomenal story and that
it's true it's crazy that a guy brought
beer to his friends in Vietnam during
wartime and actually pulled it off got
there and then the Tet Offensive happens
which is one of the biggest battles of
Vietnam right it's you can't make that
stuff up you really can't I've been on
Uso tours and I'm like I don't know how
this guy was able to pull this off but
he did yeah working with Russell Crowe
Bill Murray these are some industry vets
you know where you haven't pinched me
moments and like a sense of Osmosis like
wanting to soak things up from them what
was the experience like that yeah
definitely you know working with with
Bill Murray and with Russell Crowe is
just it's it's a dream come true but
it's it's really interesting when you
when you meet somebody like that and
you're filming a movie and you're sort
of in the process already you just start
working together and there's something
that really the great actors do that
bill and Russell did that was just they
they are so present and they care so
much about this craft that they've
they've kind of know they've mastered so
many different aspects of filmmaking
like they become more than uh your your
co-star like they help you through takes
they have ideas they they they're very
aware of their presence on camera the
characters and story and they're just
it's so fun to work with those people
and yeah like you said sort of absorb
some of the magic you just feel like
that's that's what I want to be on oh so
cool somebody Pinch Me moments
foreign